para empezar le pido que abordemos las
características del grupo de al qaeda en
el magreb islámico Cuál es su historia
grandes rasgos sus objetivos y su poder
real sobre el terreno
Buenas tardes rosa muy amable por la
invitación este grupo de al qaeda es
constituido con una de las 150.000
células que recibieron entrenamiento
directo o indirecto en Afganistán bajo
la tutela de usama Bin Laden y de allí
nacieron los salafistas que son los más
extremistas que posteriormente fueron el
embrión de Isis y tienen una presencia
importante en Argelia túnez Libia Egipto
y una ligazón muy directa con los
Hermanos musulmanes y cuando se complicó
la situación en el centro de África en
el 2012 que cayó mal y una parte de malí
en poder de los yihadistas ellos
estuvieron presentes posteriormente
Francia eliminó a uno de sus cabecillas
y también tuvieron un acto que fue muy
conocido el asalto al teatro en bamaco y
el secuestro de varias personas donde
murieron 19
seres humanos en ese combate
y le preguntó ahora por el caso más
particular del periodista Olivier Duval
conocimos hoy como decíamos la noticia
de que este grupo lo tiene secuestrado
desde hace prácticamente dos años
También aprovecho para vincularlo con el
hecho de que cada país tiene protocolos
distintos en lo que es la gestión de
secuestros con lo que considera grupos
terroristas Entonces cómo se espera que
reaccione Francia ante esta noticia
pues es un duro golpe para macron que
está empeñando toda su agenda exterior
en Ucrania y con lo que ya le hemos
visto en los medios pero es un reto
grande para Europa Porque si usted Mira
el mapa
al frente de la Costa Sur de Europa
usando el Mediterráneo está la costa
norte de África que es como la
retaguardia estratégica de lo que quiso
sama Bin Laden de colocarlo allí
entonces lo más seguro es que con este
periodista van a buscar una serie de
manipulaciones buscando concesiones y
buscando presiones para Europa pero lo
más grave Rosa que mientras tanto pueden
retornar a algo que se ha tranquilizado
un poco en Europa que son las acciones
yihadistas en cualquiera de los países
europeos y naturalmente en este caso
Francia está en la mira por haber
participado en malí por los combates que
hay y por la intención que tiene al
qaeda de controlar no solamente el
magreb islámico sino bajar al de África
y alza gel Pero disculpe particularmente
le quisiera preguntar si se espera que
Francia vaya a pagar un rescate
probablemente si Rosa Lo que pasa es que
no lo van a hacer público y utilizarán
muchos medios para desconocer que lo
hacen pero tratarán también de de
rescatarlo eso es parte de las de las
acciones y de las opciones pero sí se
verán obligados finalmente a pagar pero
quién sabe qué más es lo que quieren
estos terroristas porque ellos no van a
limitarse con una acción única sino que
buscarán más